yeah welcome to this video yeah this is
a bit different here this is whoops this
is lee chess if this is the way it is
pronounced and this is the only bullet
arena something that I recently saw on
various channels I mean kingscrusher did
videos of that and also John with on you
so I decided to give it a go and see
what this is ok I winning a pcr right
well he's taking them could have taken
III but this is also a piece yeah first
thing to mention is that I'm totally new
to this here I only have played a couple
of bullet games right before this
tournament to get warmed up and so I
have to adjust to how this site is
actually working that's nice not me this
ok still material up what I recognized
from those other videos less is best
birth Nick bears berserk mode while it
is difficult to pronounce me we can
essentially double up um okay what's
this okay it's checking me but he only
has this one check really hmm I don't
like this very much oh he's found he
found a tactic here let's troublesome
group c 6 made like okay that will let
shaky-shaky okay let's march up the
board ah time the time oops bar what
that that's that's bad right he just wow
he totally played on my time here this
guy that's rough did too
a so that was a bad start I mean okay I
was two totally winning but whatever how
is this going to Louis is working
actually so i'm going to i'm just
getting getting pairings right yeah here
i get one so here's this berserk mode i
think i should probably do that so will
be difficult because of the time it's
maybe not the right opening for this
kind of thing it to be perfectly honest
yeah you win in 30 seconds how am I
going to do that but ok maybe maybe I
can okay you cannot win the pawn on d4
because I have Jennifer okay I should oh
gee form and reroute yep check them now
ready for 95 or Bishop g5 maybe 95 him
attacking his book what's this time 17
seconds yeah I have to push hard for the
win here so I'm not really interested so
much in correct news I would just want
to be quick okay he gave this up can
check me with c4 but it's really just a
check okay like to checkmate mie he
actually resigned them okay not sure why
but it's okay so I've got three points
yeah I really have to use this berserk
mode to get points i guess it's tricky
though hey this is a pretty quick I mean
this is the server is pretty quick but
you and so you don't have delay and
things but I have to get used to the to
the hoop rain playing procedure GM who's
arts can I double here I don't know it's
a bit bit much I can only do that right
before the game
so let's play play normally here let's
see what we get one before okay I've got
a good center so I don't mind this
position at all that will get some some
kind of play on the Kings side
ultimately come on I want to go 96 now
he played it or the server plated okay
Queen up to d6 or here for a night age
for business okay he Chuck care about
that I could have taken on III actually
that was that would have been really
strong okay and d4 was also strong but
that's still in the position after g4 i
can go d for who I'm really not in
bullet I would yet this is entirely
different to normal to normal games ok
let's get this on I can that's not okay
i can just recapture here that's no
problem at all do I go D for here or not
I should have I can just take this no
problem at all and Jim
it's all fairly nice look to g5 for
example and even see that move coming
but that's still good t4 come on let's
open up the whole thing okay it wasn't
the clearest whenever but I'm yeah
there's this n someone got double of
points yeah I don't know what this is
kind of the streak thing I probably if I
win again i'm also getting getting a
streak going this is a guy oh hey this
is the guy was leading the event so I
better win this one okay Oh III of
course not yeah the mouth slip he wanted
to go afore of course but it didn't
didn't really matter I have a great
position yeah that's really excellent so
let's get NC 4 95 and like it's
basically crumbling
let's get this okay so that at least
should net me the lead in this event
after beating this guy okay I should do
berserk okay I could do that okay that's
not exactly the way to do it maybe but
I'm quick at least let's see foreign
okay that's not too bad I could have
played a five that would have been a bit
awkward right okay that's not any sort
of problem here at all it's quite nice
spedition I let's invade their rook c8
though rook c8 oops that's dead Sam
something I'm going to take I could have
taken the root it would have been a bit
better but grabbing all that is also not
bad didn't want a queen trade okay but
now Faruk b8 trade trade trade it's
always a good idea when you have two
extra 2 X 2 pieces last I have to be
relatively quick though not not a
problem in general but a problem if
you're not very used to the platform but
I'm reasonably quick just grabbing
everything here okay I one more time
actually okay that looks comfortable
here when I got 25 I don't know why I
got five now maybe cause of the berserk
okay
so let's get here again Google in 500
let's see him get some quick oops quick
moves out this is the Wayne a camera off
and place in and polishes not sure if I
can fare as well as he does probably not
but that looks kind of nice actually
getting this end for Knight to g4 oh
that's all so cute that's very nice
position ok I'm going to LA come on take
them that's very nice so just an extra
porn and a fantastic position check now
let's just be content with the winning
end game here we don't need to check
mate necessarily pre mafia ok let's see
how do I actually when trading some
stuff cannot be bad it's two pawns all
right pause a bit Empress ice but no big
deal it's just too much material I I
know I'm winning all the pawns King
before King before was a bit simpler
yeah that's really what whatever you can
see about this platform you can really
move quickly ok that wasn't made so
seven points later that looks good my
first first game was really rubbish want
it there but ok I'm ok after that let's
see can I get some beserk sin yeah
there's some pretty decently rated
players like around 2,000 berserking
there might be might be tricky
all right okay don't get a game there
they're not so many players in this
event okay like how many is that so I
don't know like 20 guys I don't see it
there so 26 okay that's probably the
number of players okay I I got a game
whose arts can I berserk let's bezerk
it's kind of it's tricky against this
kind of writing but maybe I can get some
nice attacking position
and it said at least I'm dangerous how
do i get the Queen yes King may be up to
g5 that's kind of strange but let's try
this I can over the e porn actually that
would have been interesting ok I know I
wanted to go to age 40 wow wow I wanted
to go to h4 know ok let's see can I get
some kind of some kind of swindle going
why I don't have any time because of the
berserk ah Jesus what did i do here I
need the rook here badly i know i can i
can go I my time well my time what a
disaster go into a green t XG for well
that was 30 I quite I one lost 38
reading points with this game this is
kind of ridiculous ok ok let's be sonnet
am playin on oops that wasn't intended
yeah I have a fair share of mouth lips
iam okay at least that didn't blunder
piece or anything amazing the silly
stuff you can do sometimes um okay going
to grab this one using this pin down
okay that's a check
I just take everything I could have
taken the Queen what did that take the
Queen and now I'm blundering this night
hahaha it's always I mean you have to
adjust to each other to the way that can
also check this you really have to
adjust to them to the to a different
side the whole move mechanics is
different and then i have a new mouse so
everything adds up here a little bit I
don't make that many mouths lips usually
okay check him there try to use the rook
check the rock there okay
yeah okay he goes FYI have Queen f5
check it looks quite good and it's made
okay yeah the solid play is a bit better
considering that I have to fight not
only against opponents but also against
a little bit against my mouth yeah
actually I'm also playing this
tournament because I wanted to start an
session on the on the ICC but I couldn't
because i had a server restart don't
have that often but then simply the
service basically not working well it
was working but it was just them what
was just about to be populated again my
players so it was basically impossible
together get a game going what is he
doing here night be 5 i'm taking this
it's really really weird but i have
spent nine seconds for all this let's
take this on ok maybe this one for made
on h2 yes that's good ok that was a
three-pointer yeah it's still not having
a huge gap there that that city Los
really cost me you see a long second
place ok so I really should beat this
going to make sure that is not running
away with it I'm trying something
similar as before word without
sacrificing the whole the whole board it
it's probably a better way to do it yeah
that looks quite nice with this kingdom
on e 7 let's see if I can just win their
five porn that would be really neat ok
can take that I don't mind that
and grab this one ok back to hear it
looks like a nice position I have a
great night there on f5 yeah and now
it's going to be replaced by a rook 1e6
what can I put I can't actually remove
the slide over 36 that should be even
nicer than a rogue so here we go again
he went b6 that's nice Wow got a piece
on c6 n96 that's kind of funny we cannot
even cover cover c7 but I really don't
think I am in a hurry here yeah Quincy
for b5 that explodes ok so back on on
the first place I guess it would be
funny to play berserk and in every game
but that's probably a bit ridiculous
okay so that looks kind of nice i have
some ideas here on there on the Kings
side that good I could have tea can't be
too actually ok but I'm focused on one
another play here on a king side so
don't mind it that much ok if you take
the a temperature recapture ok I can do
this I cannot play 92 because of this
intermediate thing ok but it's still
nice i have a very nice active position
his pieces are rather passive him both a
knight's look passive oh that's bad
double checking there
okay maybe operate with the pin I can
take before and obviously took that okay
so interesting but his he's taking
everything here that's kind of
problematic but still like I should
rather try to keep us night that
imprisoned mmm is there some way to play
this Bishop to e5 and then like
sacrifice I'm tons of pawns down oh no
no that exactly when you played the
night over there man what a bad game
yeah okay oh wow what did I do wow what
did I do I did something mmm no I don't
want to spectate um I want a game oh I I
actually why withdrew from the
tournament accidentally what kind of
crap is that do I have points no I don't
do I have points no I lost on that
points what kind of crap is that don't
have points wow I don't understand this
event oops and all of a sudden my mouse
is acting differently oh wow what is
this something's different here did I
adjust my mouse speed somehow I don't
know
it's kind of strange to be honest what
is this thats that's totally wrong this
after I have some real Mouse issues here
somehow this misclick has also adjusted
my mouse settings kind of weird wow like
i really have promotion
hmm it's almost impossible to play yeah
I don't know what this is my my mouse is
really acting up yeah I'm very strange
yeah I have an adjustment here for this
mouse which kind of it's just the speed
of the mausam the mouse pointer right
right on the mouth so not just a
software setup but let's a kind of this
a wheel that you can or some kind of
firm some some some buttons that you can
press and then it changes the speed and
somehow this this now happened it's very
strange cool well I feels like your
mouse is kind of it's kind of slippery
the whole process kinds real strange ah
come on let's move on to move it's all
about speed IAM do i have points again
yeah i have points again now three
points behind yeah but i don't know what
this is what did I do with my mouse them
okay so let's do this okay this is
probably the time to go berserk 1600 but
I don't really feel well here with the
small setting especially considering
that I have to play quickly
he gave me this pawn that's nice whoops
and exchange see if I can trade some
stuff can go here oh I could have taken
by Sam I didn't expect him not to cover
it I can take it next move and just
returned ok let's open up as quickly as
possible for 96 or 97 ok 12 seconds
that's not good ok check HERE of 27 for
the doubling yep
but
to be cautious with pre museum the don't
don't blunder something substantial
might happen okay it worked boom boom
I'm still down to second place okay I
think my lack of lack of experience in
this tournament is showing really have
my problems there okay give me give me a
phone please yeah yeah I get a game of
all seals maybe I should have doubled
actually because of the tournament
standings the small setting is
completely unusable it really is I'm
damned I'm some kind of slowish it's
really strange it was much better before
i had this hiccup I really felt I'm
reasonably quick there but after I made
this stranger thing that it's it I could
have taken in the queen but ok that's
not bad at all I'm for the mate that's
made come on so I'm actually I'm
equaling GM results who's our that I
playing this guy that's good so just to
win it and I'm probably leading I hope
oh he's giving me material here okay but
I'm not taking the exchange it's
probably not a bad move but don't want
to give him okay
let's see for him ah not glad mmm that's
not a good position at all mmm how do i
play can I always trading stuff mostly I
but is occupying the C file here maybe I
can I close chicken a7 I should have
played rook a5 also okay threatening
would be eight maybe this is going to
work okay could have gone let b 7
immediately that would have been a bit
better I cannot take actually because of
the Frog trick still this for trick but
I'm ahead on the clock who's this nice
it's not it's not totally easy to play
something I have some ideas not nothing
great but some ideas I can take now and
take a seven next okay let's protect
this for the moment then we're going to
try to take a seven or a seven for that
matter okay if he lost on time so I'm
actually ahead again two minutes so
probably just one more game wow what do
we had event i also had somehow I have
to make sure that I don't adjust my the
small setting that it really irritates
because all of a sudden the the mouse
pointer is totally different in terms of
speed okay so it looks actually kind of
nice oops cone it's not blunder stuff
yeah maybe I get it all right if I via
that's nice that's nice so that form
going to ops sorry so let's get this
back oh wow put it on a eight that's not
the mmm the most comfortable square ever
let's put this here okay that doesn't
look totally right but I want to want to
keep it simple okay stick that wasn't so
great i really had a better position
before but my idea is to come on to
ultimately wind b7 here I probably I
will succeed with that okay that's just
a check and done from watching i am i'm
promoting come on it's good oh wait not
Luke f2 made f5 mate f5 made there was
an f5 checkmate let's take a splatter
rook and I could have played rock h8
mate this is almost almost stalemate I
don't believe any of that did I lose on
time no i didn't what was the sound I
don't know wow what a v8 event but I
think I'm I have it right with this for
this couple of force at the end so yeah
I wanted with 44 points and wow
yeah it's kind of funny let's right here
good games yeah i totally don't know
what happened with my mouth but i think
it was it was good fun i hope you hope
you enjoyed enjoyed that little video um
i'm going to probably i'm going to make
more maybe but i have to have to just do
this this kind of this kind of procedure
there and I mean the kind of how the how
the side is reacting to the to the mouth
and everything so okay I hope it was fun
I had fun at least okay thanks for
watching